Hallo?
Hä? Wartet mal.
Warum ist jetzt mein Sound heute lauter als sonst?
Windows!
Alter, was ist das?
Windows hat einmal im Soundraum gestellt.
Zack.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Warte mal, wo ist das jetzt? Sound Settings?
Mikrofon?
Hä, ne, ist immer noch auf 80.
Das muss man nicht verstehen.
Ja gut, Windows-Logik.
Heck, weh Windows.
Ja, siehst du? Gutes Timing, ja.
Heute machen wir Five Head Sick Stream.
Ja, Sick Lang.
Ich kann euch nicht versprechen, dass das so Five Head wird, wie es im Titel drinsteht.
Wir müssen mal gucken.
Async, Await?
Oder vielleicht, keine Ahnung.
Habe ich nicht irgendwo gelesen, dass Async, Await aus SIG wieder ausgebaut wurde?
Wir machen mal eine Standard-Beispiel-Programmiersprache-Lernanwendung.
Wir machen ein Kommandozeilen-Tool, was einen Webserver startet und da ein paar Prometheus-Metriken exportiert oder sowas.
Da können wir nämlich alles üben.
Wie macht man eine Konsolen-Application, wie bindet man Libraries ein und sowas.
Ich muss wirklich sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wie viel ist heute Mindest-IQ?
Ich würde sagen 95.
Also schon sehr hoch.
Weiß nicht, ob ich das schaff, Chat
Essing Await wurde mit Green Threads replaced
Ich hab mit Ach und Krach ne Ahnung, was Green Threads sind
Ich hab aber ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung
Inwieweit das was mit Essing Await zu tun hat
Eigentlich doch nicht, oder?
Ist das nicht was komplett anderes?
Chat, Chat
Hi IQ Frage
Wisst ihr, was Green Threads sind?
Wenn nicht, kann ich versuchen zu erklären.
Aber Disclaimer, es kann sein, dass ich totalen Shit erzähle.
Wisst ihr, was Green Threads sind?
Aber wir machen mal Package Updates.
Package Updates.
Yes.
Seid vor MWR auf Hyper-V Basis läuft.
Jetzt ist das viel langsamer.
Also, okay Leute, ich versuche mal Green Threads zu erklären.
Wie gesagt, in der Hoffnung, dass es stimmt, aber es kann sein, dass es totaler Blödsinn ist.
Also, guckt lieber nochmal nach danach.
Also, Green Threads sind Threads, die nicht auf OS-Threads basieren,
sondern quasi so einen Fixed Thread Pool irgendwann initial mal beim OS anfragen,
so keine Ahnung, gib mir 12 Threads und dann da drauf quasi rein,
so, nennen wir es mal auf kleinen Seite,
Threads simulieren.
So nach dem Motto, wir haben
eigentlich nur 12 OS-Threads, aber wir tun
so, als können wir 1000
normale Threads starten. Plus, dass nicht
jeder Thread gebackt ist von einem
OS-Thread, sondern nur
theoretisch existiert.
Und die müssen dann im Zweifelsfall
warten, aber dann kriegt man da nichts von mit.
Irgendwie sowas sind Green Threads.
Frag mich nicht genau.
Wollen wir mal nachgucken, ob das stimmt,
was ich erzählt habe.
Green Threads.
Überrascht deinen Liebsten mit zeitloser Designermode.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht so ganz das, was wir wollen.
Hier, Green Threads.
Okay, guck mal.
Das ist gar nicht so falsch, was ich gesagt habe.
Gar nicht so falsch.
Gibt es das auf Deutsch?
Ne.
Aber guck mal, das ist gar nicht so falsch. Das ist ein Thread, der von irgendeiner Runtime
gescheduled wird und nichts mit einem underlying OS Thread. Also ganz so falsch war es nicht,
was ich erzählt habe. Was ich nicht ganz checke ist, was Green Threads mit Async Await zu tun haben.
Essing Await ist doch eigentlich nur syntaktisch, ähm, syntaktischer Zucker bei vielen Sprachen über entweder Eventloop-Handling oder Threat-Handling oder eigentlich weiß man gar nicht, was es unter der Haube macht.
Was ja eigentlich der Sinn auch davon ist
Du kannst quasi Asynchronen Code
Schreiben, so ähnlich wie
So ähnlich muss man sagen, ja, wie Synchronen
Und das Ganze
Im Hintergrund kümmert sich dann das jeweilige
Die jeweilige
Was ist das, Runtime
Das Async Await Function
Coloring, du schreibst das so
Als müsste man wissen, was es ist
Chat, obviously, das Essing-Away-Function-Coloring hat denen nicht gefallen.
Also haben sie Essing-Core mit den Cream-Threads-Interfaces...
Okay, ich habe absolut keinen flassen Schimmer, was das bedeuten soll.
Aber du hast recht, heute ist High-IQ-Stream.
Der Chat weiß selbstverständlich, was mit Essing-Away-Function-Coloring gemeint ist.
Oder, Chat? Also, wenn ihr das nicht wisst, dann fail.
Aber ihr wisst das alle.
So, guck mal, wir haben...
Oh, was? Was ist das hier?
Warum ging mein Pac-Man-Update nicht?
Was ist da?
Yes, yes.
Oh, geht doch.
Irgendwas mit RGB.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ich kann mir das so ein bisschen zusammenreimen.
Den gefällt quasi nicht, wie, ähm, ja, genau, so ungefährlich.
Also sprich, dass das so den Source-Code quasi verunreinigt oder sowas.
Ist das wahrscheinlich gemeint? Keine Ahnung.
So, auf Package-Updates installen.
Wir können schon mal gucken, wie man das runterlädt.
Ne, Leute. Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Wir machen das heute in Containern, wie wir es das letzte Mal ausprobiert haben.
Nicht hier OS-Updates.
Ich habe nämlich ein bisschen noch weiter gebastelt und das funktioniert jetzt relativ gut.
Das heißt, ich bin nicht mehr so anfällig für Supply-Chain-Angriffe.
Wir entwickeln das heute in einem Container.
Ja, ich verstehe das auch nicht.
Die sind einfach nicht 5-Head genug, glaube ich.
Die müssten sich Consulting im Chat holen.
Oder was meint ihr?
Da kann eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen.
Was ist aus dem NixOS-Stream geworden?
Du meinst, was im Titel stand?
Da werden wir heute Teile von sehen.
Ich habe den Stream ja nie gemacht.
Aber ich habe mit Nix Package Manager rumgebastelt.
Kann ich euch gleich zeigen.
Huge.
Ist das huge?
Naja, so huge ist es auch nicht.
aus dem Neo-Wim-Stream.
Den machen wir noch.
Sag mal, warum ist denn das so lahm?
Was ist denn hier los?
Seht ihr, wie langsam das ist?
The fuck?
Hey, jetzt ist es wieder schnell.
Arch, by the way.
Aber das ist ganz schön lahm.
Normalerweise flutscht das übelst schnell durch.
Ich glaube, ich muss mal
Rebooten.
Kann das sein, dass das rumspackt,
weil ich hier noch
eine VM laufen habe auf einem anderen
Windows-Account?
Ich muss meinen RAM
irgendwie benutzen, ja? Also...
Das wird's
ja nicht sein. Die macht ja nix I.O.-mäßiges.
Okay.
Jetzt ist es durchgerauscht.
Na gut.
Moin.
So, jetzt haben wir Package-Updates gemacht.
Jetzt machen wir nochmal hier.
Also das laggt, seit Vmware Hyper-V backt ist.
Laggt das rum.
Das sackt.
Ich glaube, ich stelle Hyper-V wieder komplett aus.
Chat, benutzt ihr Hyper-V?
Also, das ist eine blöde Frage.
Kaum einer verwendet Hyper-V direkt auf dem Desktop.
Aber benutzt ihr diese Windows-Features,
wie beispielsweise diese komische Windows-Sandbox
und diese Memory-Protection-Geschichte und sowas,
Das ist richtig scheiße, der Hyper-V Support, ja
Aber du musst ja Hyper-V verwenden in VMware oder in VirtualBox
Wenn du eben diese Security-Features von Windows eingeschaltet haben willst
Aber ich glaube, ich mach das wieder aus
Das ist echt richtig dumm
Oh, guck mal, Package-Updates sind fertig
Dann würde ich hier sagen
Rrrrrrrrrr
DSL
Stimmt
Stimmt, du hast recht. Das neue WSL ist ja auch in Hyper-V, ne? WSL 2, was ich irgendwie übelst doof finde, aber warum ist meine Musik jetzt abgekackt?
Nice! An error has occurred. Please try again later. Massive error.
Und jetzt geht es gar nicht mehr
Gibt es keine Musik mehr
Outdated, overrated, jebaited
Ja
Hier irgendwo waren wir
Glaube ich
So, da sind wir
Jetzt zeige ich euch mal
Wie nice das hier mit Containern ist
in Container entwickeln.
Ich hab mir das... Ah, guck, der Pepe muss
mal eine Runde drücken.
Aber ich nicht.
Ich war,
bevor der Stream losgegangen ist.
Ich weiß, das wolltet ihr jetzt alle wissen,
ne?
Das musste jetzt
gesagt werden.
Also, passt mal auf.
Massive Container-Entwicklungs-Stells.
Ups. Ah, die VM buggt.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Wenn du die VM gestartet hast und einmal im Fullscreen,
dann musst du hier einmal in Task Manager,
weil sonst kommst du nicht mehr rein und raus.
GachiBuzz.
Richtig dumm.
Also da muss man echt sagen, das ist total verbuggt.
Übrigens habe ich gelesen,
Microsoft ist nicht in der Lage,
den File Explorer zu entlaggen.
in Windows 11, sagen sie.
Das heißt, sie sagen, man muss damit leben,
dass der File Explorer laggt.
Da denke ich immer zurück an Windows 98.
Das war ja alles noch viel fragiler.
Aber der Kram, der ging
relativ schnell.
Also du konntest auf einem
Pentium
233, war 233
war das schon ein Pentium 2 oder war das noch
ein Pentium 1?
Ich glaube, das war schon ein Pentium 2. Das waren die
ersten Pentium 2s, ne?
233 MHz. Du konntest
das damals auf dem Pentium 2
mit 233 MHz
starten und es ist instant aufgegangen
der Explorer. Und stellt euch mal vor,
man hat damals in der Systemsteuerung
im Startmenü sogar noch was gefunden.
Ich weiß, das kann man sich gar nicht
richtig vorstellen, aber das ist echt so. Heute geht das Startmenü
auf und das erste, was ich sehe, ist
fucking LinkedIn.
Ja, Solitaire
Casual Games, Outlook.
Hier, es ist mal ernsthaft.
Das Startmenü,
Ich benutze 80% davon nicht
Edge benutze ich nicht, Outlook benutze ich nicht
Microsoft Store benutze ich nicht, Settings benutze ich nicht
Fotos benutze ich nicht, Solitaire benutze ich nicht
Snipping Tool benutze ich nicht
Notepad benutze ich manchmal, Clock benutze ich nicht
Calculator benutze ich nicht, LinkedIn benutze ich nicht
Paint benutze ich manchmal, File Explorer benutze ich manchmal
Also, das ist voller Schrott
Gibt es sogar einen Windows Shortcut, um LinkedIn im Browser zu öffnen?
Ne, das ist wichtig. Das habe ich unbedingt gebraucht.
Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Pass mal auf. Massive Fifehead Containerentwicklung stellt.
Ich erzähle das nochmal kurz, warum ich angefangen habe, so gut wie alles jetzt,
oder ich versuche zumindest so gut wie alles, warum schreibe ich fünfmal Clear und LS?
Ich bin nicht hängen geblieben.
Ihr habt ja die ganzen Supply Chain Angriffe mitgekriegt.
sei es jetzt auf npm das kommt ja gefühlt einmal in der woche vor bei npm oder auch bei maven was
java angeht und theoretisch ist da auch weder cargo rusts nougat noch sonst was davor geweiht
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wenn wir jetzt was entwickeln in zukunft machen wir das einfach in
einem container und ich habe eine nice software gefunden die nennt sich devpod die habe ich
ursprünglich als gui gestartet lag bei dir auch das lautstärke menü ja das laggt auch
Siehste? Man sieht es nicht richtig, aber das laggt auch
Das sind auch so Dinge, wo ich
die Frage, wie schafft man es, dass das
Lautstärke-Menü laggt?
Wie ist das?
Was muss man dafür
programmieren, dass das laggt?
Ich weiß nicht,
was sie bei Microsoft da treiben
Die Vibe-Coden-Windows wahrscheinlich nur noch
Meint ihr nicht auch?
Die sitzen den ganzen Tag, die programmieren einfach nicht mehr an Windows.
So, erstmal WiFi ausschalten.
Wozu WiFi?
Sagt.
Die Vibe coden das nur noch, Windows.
Sag ich euch.
Ich hab letztens ein paar Artikel gelesen, die wurden in dem .NET Subreddit gepostet.
Und da war legit AI-generierter Code drin, in einem offiziellen Microsoft-Blog-Artikel.
AI-generierter Code drin, der nicht funktioniert hat.
Da waren Variablen und Funktionsnamen identisch.
Ne, Inum, Enum-Namen und Variablen-Namen waren es, glaube ich.
Waren gleich. Das würde nicht mal kompilieren.
Dass in einem offiziellen Microsoft-Blog-Artikel irgendwas zusammen wipe-coded und released.
das mag ja alles schön und gut sein dass ein viel effektiver macht das kann ich übrigens auch
bestätigen ich gehe nicht davon aus dass uns die jobs streitig macht ich sehe aber dass man mit
teilweise unglaublich viel effektiver was machen kann ich frage mittlerweile auch öfters hier kann
man das ein bisschen schöner machen source code mäßig hast eine ahnung wie wenn man das hier in
gohard wie sieht das in in sie schabt aus und so was das frage ich ja auch ganz das macht dann
wirklich viel effektiver aber ich habe den eindruck dass fehler auch kaum noch
auffallen weil die leute den kram nehmen copy
pasten sommer drüber gucken tag auch ja passt schon wirklich richtig durchlesen
tut das keiner und es ist viel schwerer in was er generierte die fehler zu
finden weil er halt irgendwie drauf drauf labert halt gerne schafft es dass
Müll aussieht wie legit.
Und deswegen ist es ziemlich schwierig,
AI-Sachen immer Probe zu lesen.
Find ich zumindest.
Versus Sachen, die halt Leute
von Hand geschrieben haben.
Nutzt du N8n? Ne.
Windows-Updates zerstören SSDs?
Wirklich? Na geil.
Also, jetzt mal zurück zum Thema.
Normalerweise
müssten wir uns jetzt SICK installieren.
Okay, was auch immer
Normalerweise müssen wir uns jetzt SIG installieren
Oder Rust installieren oder Java installieren
Oder was auch immer wir programmieren
Und wenn wir da dann irgendwelche Libraries
Uns einfangen
Beispielsweise
Mal angenommen wir würden jetzt eine Java Anwendung machen
Machen wir nicht
Und wir würden aus irgendwelchen Gründen
PostHoc als Dependency bekommen
Dieses war, das war nämlich
Verseucht mit
Scheihulut V2
Das war ein Package, ein Java-Package mit Embedded Bun-Runtime, was dann Shaihulut ausgeführt hat.
Also das war quasi Wurm in JavaScript in Java gerappt.
So weit sind wir schon im Jahr 2025, naja, wir könnten sagen 2026.
Scheihulut
Scheihulut sind die
klingt dumm, ich weiß nicht
sind die Sandwürmer aus Dune, da gab es letztens
einen Wurm
der übrigens, wenn er nichts bei euch
angerichtet hat auf dem Rechner
zum Abschiedsgruß
noch die Festplatte gelöscht hat
also wenn er nicht
Credentials geklaut hat, eure Software verseucht
hat mit irgendeinem Müll, hat er
zumindest noch netterweise zum Ende hin
die Festplatte gelöscht
Sehr nice von denen, oder?
So, und wenn wir das
uns eingefangen hätten, dann hätten wir
das bei uns auf dem Rechner gehabt. Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt,
wir entwickeln jetzt in Containern.
Das heißt, im Zweifelsfall löscht
er den Container oder macht da irgendwas,
aber da ist ja nichts drin. So,
und jetzt, jetzt passt mal auf, ich habe da ein Programm
gefunden, das nennt sich DevPod.
Ich habe jetzt die DevPod CLI
hier am Start. Das letzte Mal haben wir
DevPod benutzt, per
GUI und das ist wie bei vielen GUIs
Schrott. GUI suckt.
GUI suckt.
Was man jetzt machen kann, wenn wir jetzt
ein neues Projekt starten, ich kopiere mir mal hier
das vom letzten Mal.
Ich habe das bei mir auch
lokal im Git-Report eingecheckt. Wir nennen
das jetzt mal hier SIG
Matrix Champ oder so.
So.
Gehen wir mal da rein.
Und was man jetzt hat, ist, man hat hier eine
Dev-Container-Datei.
Da steht so Sachen drin, wie man möchte einen Container anlegen aus diesem Docker-File und da drin dann Zeug entwickeln.
Wir nennen das mal um. Das ist nicht mal der Quarkus-Champ, das ist der Sigmetrix-Champ.
Und dann braucht man ein Docker-File, wo drin definiert wird, was man in dem Container alles zur Verfügung haben will.
Ich mache das jetzt mal exemplarisch. Ich lasse den Container für Java-Entwicklung.
Und ihr seht, ich habe das hier mit Nix Packages gemacht.
Das ist nice, da muss man sich nämlich keine Gedanken machen, ob irgendwelche Betriebssystem-Repos die Sachen anbieten.
Kann es von ausgehen, dass es bei Nix Packages alles gibt.
So, das ist jetzt mein Entwicklungscontainer für Java-Software.
Aber wir starten den jetzt einfach mal, dass ihr mal seht, wie einfach das ist.
Ich habe hier noch ein weiteres Skript, Connection.sh, sieht dann so aus.
Machen wir mal IntelliJ weg, das brauchen wir nicht.
Firefox brauchen wir an der Stelle auch nicht für das Projekt.
So, und jetzt muss ich nichts anderes machen wie
den, ähm,
das Connection-Skript sourcen.
Dev-Container fügt das alles zusammen.
Also dein Docker-File, du siehst gleich.
So, jetzt baut er erstmal anhand von dem Docker-File
das Container-Image
und dann startet
er ein DevPod-Projekt.
Das ist dann auch
ein Container, der per SSH erreichbar ist
und alles und da startet Visual Studio Code
und öffnet da drin
das Verzeichnis und alles.
Das ist richtig nice.
Beim ersten Bild dauert das relativ lang, weil es den Container
ja noch nicht gibt. Ihr seht gerade,
der baut den Container
installiert mit Nix.
Mit Nix irgendwelche
Dinger. Das jetzt noch für Java. Das müssen wir gleich
umbasteln für SICK Development.
Moin Mario.
Hast die Musik auch gerade dazu, oder?
Boah ey, warum brauchen das so lang?
Monka W.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass NixOS gerade abfuck langsam ist?
Ist das das Microsoft Dev Container Projekt?
Ne.
Das ist DevPod.
Das ist das Projekt hier.
Das ist natürlich geiler Vorführeffekt, weil euch zeigen, wie easy man hier Entwicklungskonten hat.
starten kann aber nix ist gerade übelst lahm af
jetzt breche ich das noch mal ab und starte das noch mal
vielleicht geht es jetzt schneller oder auch nicht
Ja, die Dev-Container-Specs kommen von Microsoft, das ist richtig.
Okay, wir müssen kurz warten, bis das hier fertig ist.
Anscheinend ist NixCache gerade ziemlich lahm.
Ah, ne.
Der braucht einfach nur, wenn er Java installiert.
Okay, wir brauchen gar kein Java jetzt, das ist ja nur ein Beispiel.
Kann sein, dass er ordentlich Londoner ist.
Normalerweise ist der Container schneller gebaut.
JDK ist ein dickes Ding.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Massive dickes Ding.
Huge.
Massive IQ.
Ich muss mir gleich noch einen Tee holen.
Alter, wie fett.
ist denn das OpenJDK, Alter?
Was macht denn der da?
Guck dir das mal an.
Das braucht ja drei Stunden.
Hat das einen Schlaganfall beim Lesen
des Titels?
Das hat aber den IQ eher gesenkt als erhöht.
Das ist schlecht für heute.
Heute brauchen wir den massivsten IQ
von allen zusammen hier.
Alter, OpenJDK.
Meine Güte, mach hinne.
Ich wollte es jetzt bloß... Wir brauchen das heute gar nicht.
Ich wollte es jetzt bloß mal kurz zeigen, wie schön das ist mit den Containern jetzt.
Ich habe doch hier so einen Java-Witz drin gehabt.
Ah, den habe ich wieder gelöscht.
Klopf, klopf, wer ist da?
Lange Pause. Hallo, hier ist Java.
Ah, jetzt hat er es geschafft.
Ne, immer noch nicht
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt ist der Container fertig
Er hat nur 3 Stunden gebaut
Ne, hab ich nicht mitbekommen
So
Guckt mal, wie nice das ist
Jetzt geht ein Container auf
Hier
Ich bekomme einen Editor
Äh
Was passiert hier gerade?
Alter!
Wischel Studio Code macht Dinger.
Okay, fertig. Ja, nice.
Alles klar.
Also, guck mal, ich hab jetzt hier einen Container mit meinem ganzen Java-Zeug, was ich brauch.
Also, ich mach nix Java-mäßig, aber ich hab einen Container, wo ich per SSH drauf eingeloggt bin.
Und hab hier meinen Visual Studio Code auf und kann hier Zeug machen.
Und alles das ist quasi jetzt in einem Container.
Wenn ich jetzt hergehe und bin fertig entwickeln, dann geh ich hier einfach raus, sag DevPod, Destroy.
Ich glaub, Destroy ist es. Ne, äh, Delete.
Devport delete und zack ist alles wieder weg.
Habt ihr auch gesehen, hat er wieder freigegeben.
Also ich kann quasi Container hochfahren mit genau der Software drauf, die ich brauche, um dieses Projekt zu entwickeln.
Und danach ist es wieder weg.
So, guck, wenn ich jetzt sage, ach, so jetzt ist morgen, jetzt will ich wieder anfangen, sage ich source hier, source ich wieder meinen Container, meinen Container Connection Script.
Zack, jetzt muss er den Container nicht bauen, der ist ja schon da.
Startet Visual Studio Code
Öffnet das
Öffnet mir eine SSH Session auf den Container
Und ich bin ready to go
Warum der Download
Vom Visual Studio Code Server
So lange braucht und so viel CPU Last
Verursacht, ich hab keine Ahnung
Normalerweise bei einer anderen Kiste
Macht's das nicht, aber gut
Soll mir recht sein
Ne, ich hab noch kein Battlefield 6 gespielt, immer noch nicht
Wow, what the f
Alter, die Hyper-V
Integration ist so für'n Arsch
Habt ihr das gerade gesehen, wie es einfach mal eine Taste 500 Mal repeated hat?
So, und jetzt bin ich hier drinnen.
Guck, jetzt bin ich hier in meinem Projekt.
Jetzt könnte ich hier quasi sagen, äh, Quarkus, create new project.
Wollen wir aber nicht, weil wie gesagt, ich will ja kein Java-Zeug entwickeln, sondern sick.
Und da können wir uns mal anschauen, wie schön das ist, da neue Software reinzukriegen zum Entwickeln.
Wir sagen jetzt hier, delete.
so dann gehen wir in unsere zwischen studio kommt man wieder zu dann ich glaube das packt weil ich
zwei vor allem der instanzen parallel offen hat so dann gehen wir nach def container in unser docker
fall so und was brauchen wir nix us wir gucken jetzt wie das package heißt mit nix bei nix sick
sich so da gehen wir einfach hin schmeißen den ganzen java krempe raus installieren nix
und das war's und schon ist unser container einsatzbereit für nix für nix development
jetzt ist er nicht nichts sich habe ich nichts development gesagt sich development
zu viele abkürzungen ok install in sick 0 15 0.15 punkt 2 container ist gebaut
es gibt eine Visual Studio Code Session
auf die Kiste
es gibt eine SSH Session
und zack, da sind wir
und können loslegen
ist das nicht nice?
schon habe ich alles
installiert, was ich brauche
ich habe einen Container und wenn ich fertig bin, schmeiße ich den wieder weg
und ich bin nicht
ähm
und ich bin nicht mehr so anfällig für irgendwelche Supply Chain
Angriffe
hat das einen grund dass du beim run command in den docker falls explizit
gleich aus ja hat wahrscheinlich bin ich einfach nur zu blöd aber ich kann dir
sagen warum du meinst du meinst das hier
warum ich hier warum ich hier bash aufrufe das liegt daran weil ich login
skript ausführen will ich will login skript ausführen die in
Profile unter BashRC drinstehen.
Wenn man einmalig irgendwie sowas
machen könnte,
wäre auch gut. Hätte ich auch nichts dagegen.
Aber weiß ich nicht wie.
Also falls du da irgendwie
High IQ Lösung für hast, dann
muss das
nicht so bleiben.
Aber das ist schon
nice. So und ich kann jetzt übrigens hier auch mit
DevPod gucken, was gerade läuft.
Ach guck mal, der Quarkus-Champ vom letzten Mal läuft noch.
Den können wir mal löschen.
DevPod, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, wie das geht, wenn man Sachen deletet, die...
Dann weiß ich nicht, wie man das löscht, wenn man nicht im Ordner drin ist.
Aber wir können das...
CD Download.
Das habe ich das letzte Mal noch über das GUI angelegt, deswegen geht das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Essliche GUI hier.
Brauchen wir nicht mehr.
GUI ist overrated, outdated, jebaited.
Er hat den Namen auch doppelt eingefügt.
Was wie wo? Hier?
oder was meinst du?
Monk HW?
Achso!
Ach stimmt!
Also da muss man wirklich sagen, die VM läuft nicht gut.
Das ist das Hyper V based Sackt.
also jetzt habe ich hier meinen container und meine idee offen jetzt kann ich anfangen und
das geile ist wenn ich fertig bin möchte ich das und das ist einfach wieder weg und ich bin
nicht anfällig für so und nicht so anfällig für supply chain angriff also eigentlich weiß so sick
gibt es da irgendwie ein getting started oder sowas getting started release was haben wir
denn jetzt eigentlich installiert für den SIG?
5?
Gibt es da sowas wie Version?
SIG Version?
Ah ja.
0.15.2. Ist das denn die aktuelle?
SIG Version.
Was ist denn die aktuelle
Version?
SIG Version.
16 Dev?
15?
Okay.
16?
Ach nee, 16 ist quasi die aktuelle Entwicklungsversion.
Und 15.2 ist die letzte Release-Version.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Okay.
Na dann.
Dann wollen wir mal.
Chat, hat irgendjemand von euch Ahnung von SIG?
Weil manchmal ist es ganz hilfreich,
wenn man leute der hat zumindest ein bisschen plan so sagen wir mal unser
container rein und sagen jetzt sich ja wie erstellt man ein projekt sei
irgendwie irgendein example dafür recommended tools syntax run hell over
sich in
Gibt es da kein... Doch, du kannst auch normale Docker-Container verwenden.
Das macht nur die Handhabung ein bisschen einfacher.
Wobei, du kannst ein paar Sachen machen, die kannst du bei normalen Docker-Containern nicht so einfach machen.
Und zwar, wenn wir jetzt mal hier reingucken in dieses Dev-Container-JSON.
Du kannst beispielsweise ein Kommando ausführen, nachdem der Container gestartet wurde.
So, gut, das geht in zwei Ecken natürlich mit dem normalen Docker-Container auch.
Du kannst Ports weiterleiten hier drinnen, kannst du im normalen Docker auch.
Das macht es eigentlich nur vom Handling her ein bisschen angenehmer.
Du kannst auch einen normalen Docker-Container starten.
Es mountet dir beispielsweise standardmäßig dein Projektverzeichnis schon rein in den Container, ohne dass du es selbst angeben musst.
Aber du könntest einfach auch einen normalen Docker-Container starten.
Was es auch noch macht, ist installiert er den Visual Studio Code Server oder den IntelliJ Backend in den Container rein
Das müsstest du sonst halt auch selbst machen
Also wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel sage
Warte mal, ich mach das gerade nochmal zu
Ich zeig's euch mal
Wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel reingehe und sage, da muss ich das nochmal anpassen.
Hier, Dev-Container-Connection.
Wo habe ich denn hier meinen, hier, wenn ich das da.
Ups.
So, mal angenommen, ich will jetzt IntelliJ öffnen anstatt Zwischenstudio Code.
Max, was denkst du, ist gute Zertif...
AZ-900.
AZ-900 habe ich auch gemacht.
Oder war es nicht 901 sogar?
Das ist Azure, das ist eine Azure-Schulung.
Ganz ehrlich,
ihr wisst, ich bin kein großer Fan von
Zertifikaten, also
kann ich nichts zu sagen.
So, wenn ich da jetzt IntelliJ reinschreibe,
dass ich das verwenden will dann erstellt er das neue und guck der download und installiert mir
auch das intelli j back end jetzt schon in den container rein und eröffnet dann auch intelli
j und verbindet sich deswegen das was wir das letzte mal ausprobiert haben mit dem gui das
gui ist richtig die die kommandos die kommandozeilen app ist viel besser von den für
Dev-Container. Guck, man sagt
dem jetzt hier, ich will IntelliJ benutzen.
Machen wir gleich nochmal anders.
Jetzt müsste ich eigentlich das mit dem Browser machen.
So, jetzt wird IntelliJ drauf.
Das müsstest du halt sonst alles selbst machen
in deinem Docker-File.
So, jetzt wird IntelliJ
Extracted, was gerade
super lahm ist alles auf meiner Firm, aber
müssen wir jetzt durch
Genau, guck
SSH geht auf, Browser
geht auf, fragt ob man das IntelliJ öffnen
will und dann macht er schon quasi
die Connection dahin
selbstständig.
Guck und jetzt,
zack,
geht gleich IntelliJ auf und hat
das Projekt geladen.
Äh,
whatever.
Das muss er wahrscheinlich nur
einmal machen, denke ich.
So, zack, und jetzt geht IntelliJ auf
Und ich hab eine IDE, die in den Container
Connected ist, das kannst du sicherlich alles
Selbst machen, mit einem Docker-File
Aber das ist mit DevPod viel einfacher
Guck, jetzt bist du hier drinnen
Mit deiner IDE im Container
Also ich find das recht nice
So
Gehen wir mal hier raus, machen das wieder
Rückgängig, wir wollen
Visual Studio Code haben, übrigens, Chat
PyFat-Kommando
Wer weiß, ohne nachzugucken, was das hier macht.
IIQ-Check.
Ich kopiere es mal raus.
Das holt sich den Namen
Vom aktuellen Verzeichnis
Und macht
To lower
Das hier ist Bash Magic
Für aktuellen Fahrt
Und da nur den letzten Teil davon
Also er nimmt den hinteren Teil
Vom aktuellen Verzeichnis
Nur das aktuelle Verzeichnis
Nicht den Fahrt davor
to lowercase. Und ich bin mir relativ
sicher, man kann das hier wahrscheinlich
sogar auch in Bash Build-In
machen, dass man das TR gar nicht braucht.
So, okay.
Jetzt connecte ich mich
in meinen Container.
Da haben wir unser SIG-Zeug am Start.
Ich finde das
richtig nice.
So.
Also, SIG-Init
Stand da, müssen wir machen.
SIG-Init.
Bäm!
Was haben wir denn hier?
Wir haben eine Main SIG, eine Root SIG.
Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal die Visual Studio Code Extension für SIG installieren.
Was da?
Trust Publisher Uninstalled.
Und nachdem Visual Studio Code jetzt im Container läuft,
selbst
was
install
und jetzt
geht's jetzt
ah ja, okay, wir haben zumindest
schon mal Syntax Highlighting
ja genau, Extensions kannst du
auch in den Dev-Container-JS gleich mit angeben
und sowas, du kannst das alles selbst machen
mit einem Docker-Container, aber das ist halt viel
mehr convenient.
Ja, naja, ich weiß.
Kannst du auch machen. So, gucken wir mal, ob wir Autocomplete haben.
std. haben wir.
Weiß. Autocomplete
beste. Und dieses komische,
dumme
AI-Feature
kann sich mal
verpissen.
Piss dich, Aldo!
So, Tests brauchen wir nicht. Alles first try,
fehlerfrei.
Kommentare brauchen wir
auch nicht und so jetzt muss ich mich erst mal zurechtfinden weil man das war
alles weg
dass man halbwegs übersicht hat also das ist so was wie man in jeder x
beliebigen programmiersprache hat der einstieg standard debug print ok print
Printen wir mal was anderes.
Printen wir mal
Cute Chat.
Und dann machen wir das da weg.
Und dann sagen wir,
lass mich mal raten,
Sigrun.
Ne, Mist.
Das wäre jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen.
Sigbuild.
Ah.
Wow.
Das fängt ja schon gut an.
Compilerfehler direkt
Hello World
Okay, es gibt einen Compilerfehler, aber hier
im Editor wird schon mal
nichts angezeigt, was hat er denn überhaupt
was will er von mir
Hier, das mag er nicht
Cute Chat
Function Declared
hier
Äh
Expected
Two Arguments, found one
Warum will der ein zweites Argument haben
Ich hab doch überhaupt nichts zum Einsatz
Okay, machen wir irgendwie 1 oder so.
Okay, so geht das nicht.
Warte mal.
Okay, wir setzen mal was ein.
Wie war das eben?
Prozent S.
Ne, S und dann hier hinten ein String.
Rein.
0 W.
Okay, geht gut los.
Ähm.
Oh, ich muss ja noch alles machen.
Ey, wenn...
Wenn Hello World schon nicht funktioniert...
Aha.
Für Editor Errors muss man erst einen Check-Build-Step erstellen.
Wie mache ich das denn?
Also, was machen die hier?
Okay, machen wir dann Backslash-N.
Arx?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
What?
Was ist das denn für eine Syntax?
Das sieht ja massive eklig aus.
Ja, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Guck mal mal, ob das jetzt funzt.
Ah, jetzt hat es gebildet.
Das ist die
SigObjectNotation.
Aber warum brauche ich
da einen Tuppel? Ich meine, ich will doch...
Okay, das muss man sich vielleicht einfach dran gewöhnen.
Ähm, wo liegt denn jetzt mein Programm rum?
Sig out, hä?
Sig out, bin.
Matrix Champ, da ist er.
Zack, Funst.
So, jetzt ist die Preisfrage.
Das ist mir ja immer wichtig.
Wie self-contained ist dieses ganze Ding?
Es ist not a dynamic executable.
Das heißt, von der Idee her,
Ich kann es so ein bisschen wie Go auf jedes x-beliebige Linux-Ding kopieren und ausführen.
Das probieren wir doch jetzt gleich mal aus.
Machen wir mal hier.
Docker run.
Ubuntu.
So, warte, wir müssen das hier noch mounten.
Minus V.
Sig out.
nach
Sig
Debian Trixi. Ja gut, da wird es schon
drauf laufen.
Sig
Ach, es ist Sig
minus out, nicht Sig.out
So
Okay, auf Debian Trixi läuft das Ganze.
Das wäre mich jetzt aber auch gewundert, wenn nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Dann probieren wir doch mal was ganz dieses aus.
Ubuntu 18.04.
Da bin ich zuversichtlich, dass es auch noch läuft.
Wahrscheinlich läuft es auf allen, aber gucken wir mal.
Sig, Bin.
Ups.
Läuft.
Sehr gut.
Äh, komm.
Ubuntu 8.04.
Leute, meint ihr, das läuft auch auf Ubuntu 8.04?
Das ist von 2008.
Oh, nee.
Das gibt's nicht mehr.
Es gibt kein...
Moment.
Das ist so alt, das gibt's nicht mehr.
Das gibt's nicht mehr.
Naja, 12.04 gab's noch, warum soll's nicht 8.04 geben?
Okay, 10.04.
Was, was, unsuper.
11.04?
Okay, 12.04 hab ich instinktiv schon das...
Moment, hä? Habe ich nicht eben 12.04 schon gemacht?
Hat es einen bestimmten Grund, dass du dir keine eigene Mailadresse hostest,
oder einfach Bequemlichkeit?
bequemlichkeit mailing mail host sagt okay hier haben 1204 1204 ist das älteste
ob und wo was wir kriegen können sich so chat chat gehen was meint ihr tut er auf
ubuntu 10 04 oder nicht also ich sag ja da tut weil es ist ein komplett static
binary ich sag der tut ich mache jetzt kein poll oder so aber ja easy beim geht
also das ding sich produziert anscheinend wirklich komplett statische
self content binaries das finde ich sehr gut das ist schon mal ein großer pluspunkt
Punkt für mich.
Das finde ich nice.
Excellent finde ich das.
Excellent.
Gut.
Dann.
Weiter im Text.
Was machen wir denn jetzt als nächstes?
Ich würde sagen.
Als nächstes.
gucken wir mal, wie man einen Webserver startet.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Wir gucken als nächstes,
weil ich brauche hier einen Background Thread, um
Zeug zu aktualisieren. Wir gucken,
wie man einen Background
Thread spawnt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Gibt es sowas wie, ähm,
LN? Ne, gibt es nicht.
Aber was habe ich, was habe ich da
gesehen? Use, was?
Use standard log functions for proper logging.
Ach, das ist nicht proper logging.
Okay, also was?
Standard log.
Oh, das wäre ja mega nice, wenn SIG so ein structured logging Ding wie Go eingebaut hätte.
Log info.
Und kann man das jetzt genauso machen wie...
So.
Jetzt.
Warte mal.
Sig, Build und und.
Sig, Out.
Ach, der schreibt dann einfach nur Info davor.
Ja, gut.
Ach, Sig, Build, Run.
Ah.
Gibt es auch sowas wie Watch?
Wow.
Ups, was jetzt, Alter?
Was zum Teufel ist jetzt los?
Wonka S., Alter.
Memory Address
leaked.
Äh, was hab ich gemacht?
Help.
Moment, wenn ich nach Les pipe, dann krackt er ab.
Oh, guys.
Oh, ein Pipe.
Ach so, Les gibt es nicht.
Ich habe kein Les installiert.
Was ist das denn?
Lul.
Das muss da um einen Docker-File später rein.
Okay, so.
Watch.
Continuously rebuild when source files
are modified.
Ja.
Kennt hier jemand
einen Terminal File Management Video
Live Preview bekommen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Kann mein Image Viewer das?
ähm
Download
Ich brauch mal ein Video, haben wir hier irgendein Video?
Also ich mein
Äh, mein GIF
GIFs kann mein Terminal
Das heißt potenziell kann das auch Videos
Ich bin mir nur nicht sicher, ob mein Imagecat
das kann mit Videos
BigBugBunnyMP4
Das ist so das Standard-Ding.
Was ist das für eine Seite, Alter?
Ja, 30 FPS, normal.
Unzip
ImageCat
Ne
Das kann
Das kann mein ImageCat nicht
Was macht denn ImageCat eigentlich nochmal
das habe ich hier irgendwo in meiner shell ein bisschen zeit tracking
ach so das macht nur svg das kann nur bilder dass das kann nur bilder
ach du kannst wieder zum tor mit abspielen aber nicht im fall
dann kann ich dazu nichts sagen keine ahnung
Ähm
Warum kackt denn
Sick Build Watch ab
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen
Guck mal, der führt das einmal aus
Und dann kackt er ab
Liegt das an meinem Programm
Aber in meinem Programm ist ja nichts drin
Was irgendwie komisch
Was hier abkacken kann, oder
Was ist denn das?
Ausrufezeichen wollt.
Okay.
Passt mal auf.
Wir fragen mal Chat-GPT.
Ach ne.
Ach Mist, ich hab das ja in T-Mux.
No.
Da kann ich nicht richtig scrollen drin.
It's not my code.
Disable Six Leak Detection.
Bam.
Allow Inferior Leaks.
Okay, also sehe ich das richtig?
Die haben einen Memory Leak drin?
Also das ist
es liegt aber nicht an mir.
Weiß nicht.
Wollen wir mal eine andere SIG-Version
ausprobieren? Was benutzt du für eine
SIG-Version WTF-Plub?
Hast du 16?
Liegt wohl nicht nur
Inferior. Ja, anscheinend.
Okay.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen,
ähm, Nix Packages
haben die auch, haben die auch, ähm,
Du hast auch 15.2 von Nix Packages?
Hä?
Moment, dann verstehe ich es nicht.
Dann machen wir jetzt mal einmal ganz den MKDia Temp.
Wir machen nochmal ein neues hier.
SIG-Init. Ohne irgendwas
drin. Dann SIG-Build
minus minus
Run minus minus Watch.
Nö.
Vielleicht ein Problem
unter Debian?
Vielleicht ist es ein Problem unter Debian?
Könnte das sein?
Auf welcher
Aber was
Was hat der für Schmerzen
Ich glaube damit beschäftigen wir uns jetzt aber nicht weiter
Sonst dauert das wieder 3 Stunden
Bis wir was gescheites
Die Reihe kriegen
Keine Ahnung was
Sig da macht
Gehen wir mal zurück
Dann sagen wir einfach nur
Sig build run ohne watch
Das funst
Okay
Also, wie spawnt man
Einen Threat
In SICK
So, nochmal
Als übelster Kacknoob, der keine Ahnung
Von SICK hat, würde ich mal sagen
Standard
Threading oder sowas
Standard Threat, das klingt schon mal gut
Ähm
Spawn
Klingt auch gut
Okay, jetzt hört es aber schon auf
Jetzt weiß ich nicht, was da hin muss
Spawn-Config
Comp-Time-Function
Anytype
Arcs-Anytype
What? Okay
Da müssen wir suchen danach
Ne, das ist Rust
Ne, ne, ne, ne
Fast, fast
Ähm, sick
Rats
Aha
War Threat gleich
Try
Das ist wahrscheinlich
Sowas wie
In Go schreibt man ja immer
If Error ungleich
Nil und sowas
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das hier ist das gleiche
Nur dass man sich das If sparen kann
Und das Ding crasht, wenn der Error quasi
Wenn es ein Error gesetzt ist
Oh, was ist das für eine Syntax, Mann?
Standard Threads Spawn?
Okay, Spawn-Config.
Gibt es hier irgendwie Autocomplete drin?
Aha.
Ach, das ist quasi einfach nur Config.
Okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Was ich ein bisschen merkwürdig finde, ist, dass das so explizit hingeschrieben werden muss.
Das ist quasi, es gibt keine Argumente, sozusagen.
So, und das hier ist die Function, die der aufrufen soll.
Also brauchen wir jetzt hier eine Function.
Nehmen wir mal hier den Ticker.
Wild, true, standard, sleep.
Bla, bla, blub.
Das machen wir weg.
Und wir machen einfach hier drinnen unsere Standard-Ausgabe.
War das kein Auto-Format?
Function wird wie übergeben?
Ticker nennen wir es Updater.
Step brauchen wir nicht.
Ohne Argumente.
Arx.
Lass mich raten. Arx ist auch wieder so?
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Och.
Ich hab ja keine Argumente.
Ach, da mussten sie Mikolon hintendran.
So.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funzt.
Ach, guck mal.
Autoformat geht's nur, wenn's keine Syntaxfehler mehr sonst gibt in dem Programm.
Okay. Run.
Das war ja klar
Time has no
Member named Sleep
Das ist ja toll, dass im
Ist das der offizielle Guide?
Ich weiß nicht, dass es im Guide drinnen steht, aber da
Okay, sind wir mal ganz nubig
Dann gibt es bestimmt einen Thundered
Threat Sleep
Ha
Und dann kommt das da rein
So
Und jetzt, bam.
Fuck.
Was ist da denn für Schmerzen?
Du musst die Klammern weglassen beim Funktionsaufruf.
Ah, ich hab den 3.1 Guide offen.
Ah, aber es gibt noch gar keinen 15er Guide.
Was genau hat er denn jetzt für Schmerzen?
Unable to evaluate
CompTimeExpression.
Ach, hier.
Ah, ja, du hast recht.
Das würde Sinn machen, dass man das weglassen muss.
Ah, und das muss ich jetzt
tryen.
Try.
Ist ignored
War Threat
Gibt es, Moment, Moment, es gibt doch bestimmt sowas wie ignore, oder?
Ah, guck mal, es läuft jetzt
Achso
Ja, Moment, aber das beendet sich ja gleich wieder
Ich, ich spawne einen Threat
Und
danach
beendet sich mein Programm.
Das kann ja eigentlich
nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache sein.
Okay, ich brauche sowas wie eine
Console Readline.
SIG Readline.
Input.
Gibt es sowas wie
Standard
I.O.?
Ah.
In? Standard?
Okay, nee, keine Ahnung.
Readline ist eklig, wirklich?
Okay, dann machen wir das anders.
Dann machen wir einfach
Standard Thread Sleep.
Keine Ahnung, 10 Sekunden.
Sind das überhaupt Sekunden oder ist es jetzt eine Nanosekunde?
Keine Ahnung.
Run.
Es funzt.
Mein Background Thread.
Threaded.
Und nach 10 Sekunden ist aus.
Ah gut, macht ja auch Sinn.
Da ist ja meine Main Methode fertig.
Okay, wir haben einen Thread gestartet.
das ging gar nicht so
schlecht, oder?
Die Syntax ist
ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig, hier mit diesem
Punkt, geklammere.
Aber im Großen
und Ganzen
geht's klar, finde ich.
Oder was
denkt ihr? Ich finde, das ist ganz okay.
Also bis jetzt
noch keine Abartigkeiten
wie in C++ und
auch keine super Feilfeld-Syntax
wie in Rust. Bis jetzt finde ich, kann man
sich das noch durchaus geben.
So.
Jetzt wird's kompliziert.
Jetzt die Frage, wie
starten wir einen Web-Server?
Bin
bin ab nächstes Jahr
Project, was ist das? Owner
und Teamlead. Irgendwelche
Tipps? Ne, also
ein paar Technik-Sachen kann ich
dir Tipps geben, aber für Management-Sachen
nicht.
Da habe ich absolut keine Ahnung
von. Da will ich auch
nichts mit zu tun haben.
Vielleicht der Chat.
Chat ist ja heute, sieht man schon
im Titel, High IQ. Vielleicht haben wir ja im Chat
jemand. Aber
ich kann da nichts zu sagen.
So Management-Kram will ich nicht machen.
Das ist nicht
meins.
So, also wie starten wir
einen Web-Server in SICK. Okay, SICK Documentation HTTP Server. SICK Language Reference, HTTP.
Hab ich doch da irgendwo gesehen. Hier, guck mal.
HTTP.
Und wie soll das jetzt
Ein paar Examples wären ja nicht verkehrt
Was, Server? Gab's auch?
So ein paar
Examples wären schon ganz nice.
Vielleicht gibt's das ja hier
in dem Guide.
Komm, mal suchen
nach HTTP.
Ne.
Okay, also
ein bisschen mehr Examples wären schon nice.
Ach hier, Server.
Standard HTTP Server.
Das ist äußerst minimalistisch die Doku.
Okay, Standard-HTTP-Server.
Suchen wir mal danach.
SICK.
Example.
SICK-HTTP-Server.
Aha.
sekt peter war konstat rass pass ipv4 und port address listen die in it handle
connect okay das ist doch erstmal nicht verkehrt aus
Gibt es da nicht ein richtig nice Emote für Listening?
Ach, ich bin jetzt nicht eingeloggt.
Ich habe Listening hinzugefügt.
so genau das meinte ich auch okay da machen wir jetzt einfach weil weil true ok ok wir
machen nicht weil wir machen weil true threat sleep 1 die etwas nicht so endlos schleifige
Variante.
Okay.
Lauscht
der jetzt auf Port 80?
Netstat.
Uptinstall.
Net.
Utils.
Tools.
Netstat.
Der läuft. Okay, der lauscht auf
Port 8080. Was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt
einen Curl dahin mache?
Local Host, Port 8080.
Dann hängt er. Ja gut, ich antworte
hier auch nichts drauf.
Ach, jetzt kackt das aber ab.
Okay.
Okay, ja gut, macht ja auch Sinn.
Machen das hier mal zu. Hier unten SSH'en wir nochmal.
Auf den SICK.
Okay, also das
funzt schon mal. Zumindest ist der Webserver offen
auf Port 8080.
Jetzt ist die Frage, wie antworten wir das?
Da war es drauf auf Port 8080.
So, Handle Connection.
Handle Connection.
Dann kopieren wir uns das hier mal rüber.
Okay, jetzt sollte der Hello World ausspucken.
So einfach ist es nicht.
Expected Type, IO Reader, Found Net Server Connection.
Aha.
Ich weiß, aber ich bin Netzdead-Enjoyer.
Chat, seid ihr
Netstat-Enjoyer oder benutzt ihr SS?
SS ist das neue
Command, was man jetzt
eigentlich verwenden soll.
Aber ich bin Netstat-Enjoyer.
Stimmt, und in Deutschland ist es vielleicht besser.
Man bleibt bei Netstat.
Netzzeitbeste.
Einfach Aliasten, so wie NeoFetch.
Zu FastFetch.
So, also das ist schon...
Naja, so alt ist das noch gar nicht. Guck mal, das ist vom Januar
2025.
Also entweder
ist das hier ein AI
generateter
Kram
oder die haben seit Januar
was an ihrer API geändert.
Januar 2025 ist uralt.
Das stimmt.
Die Kurzsituation von NS
ist von Netzdennis NS dann.
Was ist los hier mit den Linux-Kommandos?
0.15 würde das ganze
I.O.-Interface geändert.
Okay, nice.
Okay, das heißt, wir gucken mal
Zig
Zig Change Log
Releases
Release Notes
Aber wir haben
15.2
gibt es keine Release Notes
HTTP
http kummer hier hatte tp client und server api sein implementations have been completely
reworked geil erstmal ein tutorial von 2025 aufgemacht outdated overrated gb
server api no longer die pens und standardnet relies on reader and writer
ok so war es vorher so ist es jetzt
ok lass mal kurz checken
Also das brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Das brauchen wir auch nicht mehr. Das brauchen wir noch. Stream Close. Connection.
Okay.
Achso, das heißt jetzt Server. Receive Head.
Was ist das denn?
4096, wenn schon.
Na, ist das jetzt wirklich schöner geworden in der Anwendung?
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Äh.
Receive Head.
Warum nicht eigentlich Receive Five Head?
So, findest du es jetzt?
Okay, es
kompiliert schon mal, Leute.
Curl
Local Host 8080.
Bam!
Hello world da sind wir http server am start
Moment
Jetzt gibt es 30 milliarden requests
Ist nicht wirklich ach guck mal da geht gar nicht weiter wie kleiner wie 0,1
Okay, also hier macht er schon mal http-Stells und gibt auf Standard Out unseren Update Code
aus, der nicht wirklich was updatet.
Direkt Sig in Lebenslauf, genau.
Wir haben ja Sig schon mal im Stream gemacht vor 2 Jahren oder 3 Jahren.
Aber wir haben schon wieder alles vergessen.
Okay, also wir haben einen Threat gespawnt und haben einen HTTP-Server am Start.
Zehn Jahre drauf.
Oh, cringe.
Just listen.
So.
Dann würde ich sagen...
Wie gibt man
Random-Nummern aus?
Wir geben jetzt mal ein bisschen Random-Kram aus.
Hier auf...
Wir geben aus Hello World und dann...
Moment.
Aha, das ist die Frage. Wie macht man das dynamisch?
Also,
erstmal checken, wie man eine Random-Nummer ausgibt.
Zig, Random.
Random Numbers.
Alter, was?
Okay, das ist nicht so schlimm wie in C++, aber...
...sieht hässlich aus.
Standard, Rant, Default, Brünge.
Init.
Cryptographically Secure Random.
Okay, das ist kürzer.
Mir ist egal, ob die cryptographically secure sind oder nicht.
Hauptsache, das ist kurz.
Standard Crypto Random.
Also, Standard Crypto Random.
Und dann was?
Int.
Und jetzt?
Ach, da gibt man...
Das finde ich schick.
Das finde ich schick
In Go wäre das jetzt
U8 oder irgendwie sowas
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz schick
Dass man sagt int
Und das dann limitieren kann
Das finde ich ganz nice
War
U8
So jetzt ist die große Preisfrage
Wie schreibe ich das in einen String?
Gibt es sowas wie Sprintf oder sowas?
Sprintf?
Ähm.
Interpolate String.
Sick.
Aha.
standard standard sprint f sind
was ist eigentlich der anwendungsfall von sick also wo wird das wirklich nirgends wo
interpol sing to baffa
A chill guide.
Jawoll.
Alter.
String builders and buffers.
What?
Alter.
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Standard Array List?
Inked L...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich will einfach nur
einen Text mit einer Zahl drin.
Was zum...
Was wollen die von mir?
Standard Mem Trim?
Warum Standard Mem?
What the fuck?
Okay, String Handling sieht ja nach Ultra Pains Champ aus.
Ignorier das, ist das schon nicht mehr aktuell oder was?
Standard Ascii.
Alloc to Upper.
what the fuck
ich habe absolut keinen blassen schimmer was sie von mir wollen hier
wir fragen euch fragt nochmal chat gpt
How to get the random number inside a string?
Or Buffer.
Was zum...
Ernsthaft?
Ah, STDFMT!
Das klingt gut!
STDFMT!
Print...
Print.
Aha, da kommen wir der Sache schon näher.
Buff.
Nee, Buff Print.
Buff Print.
Ah, so.
Okay.
Ein bisschen eklig ist es aber schon, oder?
Ja.
Au B6.
Nee, geh mal bloß weg.
So ein bisschen eklig ist es ja schon.
Gibt es sowas wie...
Was ist das? Z?
Z?
Print int?
Okay, also Buffprint ist auf jeden Fall schon mal richtig.
Also brauche ich quasi sowas hier im Endeffekt.
Buffer.
So, und hier kommt jetzt der FMT-Gedöns hin.
Also, Hello Chat, dann Prozent D vermute ich mal für Zahl und dann wieder diese komische Syntax hier mit, ähm, ne, Rand, so.
Achso, Komma
Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen?
Ah, das muss ich
Muss ich das als Pointer oder so übergeben
Okay
Anscheinend ist das Pointer Syntax
Rant
Ah, it's never mutated
Wollen wir auch nicht
Also ist es wahrscheinlich Let
Nope
War
Let
SICK
Gibt es da vielleicht was für?
Kunst
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert
Weil ich hier gestrickt
Ah, try
Try, okay, okay, okay, try
Try
Oh
Fuck, was will er denn?
all non voyage values must be used to discard the value ach so
alter was was ist jetzt was hat er jetzt für schmerzen address in use was denn jetzt los
Print Alloc
Das ist gut zu wissen
Das probier ich gleich aus
Ähm, was hat er denn jetzt hier gerade
Für Schmerzen
Address is in use
Hat er sich nicht richtig beendet oder was
Ne
Hä
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Was auch immer.
Okay, aber das Funds noch.
So, jetzt ist die Frage, wie kriegen wir hier...
Also, wie war das Print-Alloc?
Sagt der Chat.
Falls es das noch gibt.
Ja, das ist echt hier...
Alloc.
Alloc Print gibt es.
senti sentinels so ein bisschen hilfe text zu den funktionen wer teilweise auch ganz nice
ok jetzt brauche ich einen locator da habe ich schon mal was drüber gelesen
lesen. Zack.
Guck mal, da gibt's... Ja.
Standard
Heap Page Allo...
Was?
Was wollen die von mir?
Okay, also ich meine,
das hier können wir ja schon mal ausfüllen.
Hello Chat.
Newline. So. Und dann hier
eine Zahl.
Also die Syntax finde ich eklig hier mit
diesen komischen Punkt-Klammern
noch etwas random.
So.
GPA.
GPA-Allocator.
Standard
Heap General Purpose
Allocator.
Äh.
Was?
Chat, könnt ihr diesem Guide folgen, was der mir sagen will?
Was mache ich hier überhaupt?
Und jetzt sage ich hier Allocator.
Ach, hier sind mir Kolon.
Okay, so, run.
Bam. Es runnt, Leute.
Ach so, ich bin ja blöd.
Ich übergebe das ja gar nicht.
So, respond.
Ach so, Moment, was gibt denn der jetzt eigentlich zurück?
ach so hier das ist ja hier ist hier ist ja der content wenn wir den mal so und
das ist nicht wahr sondern konst konst content hello chat was hat er denn warum
Was will der von mir?
Warum ist das immer in use?
Ich beende den doch vorher.
Nicht General Purpose Allocator.
Der ist schlecht und deprecated.
Du brauchst SMP Allocate.
Was zum Teufel?
Woher soll man das denn wissen?
SMP Allocator brauche ich.
Der ist besser oder was?
Okay, das ist jetzt besser, oder wie?
Not a function.
What the hell?
Du kannst direkt Standard Heap SMP Allocator.
Aha, man braucht das hier oben gar nicht.
Also kann ich quasi sagen, hier Allocator gleich Standard Heap SMP Allocator.
Kann ich das so sagen und dann...
Aha, wir haben was gelernt.
Kommt mal hier, Chad.
Es ist random.
Easy.
First try.
Okay, es ist random.
Was mich jetzt ein bisschen fertig macht, ist, was will der denn immer mit Address in Use?
Ich beende das Ding mit Ctrl-C.
Hängt der dann im Hintergrund noch irgendwie rum oder so?
Näh.
Doch!
Guck mal, der bleibt im Hintergrund noch hängen.
Ich beende den aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht.
Ja, aber wenn ich Ctrl-C klicke, händelt der nicht irgendwie die Basic-Signale?
Im Hello World Example.
Weiß ich nicht, jetzt habe ich ja alles gelöscht.
Hahaha.
Defer vergessen.
Nö.
Muss ich
Ich muss doch jetzt nicht explizit irgendwie
Ctrl C oder so handeln oder
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
Dass man hier irgendwie
Signals handeln muss
Vielleicht der separat gestartete Thread
Dann sollte aber nicht Port 80 offen sein.
Ne, aber...
Ah, warte mal.
Vielleicht müssen wir tatsächlich irgendwie sagen...
Red?
Was gibt es denn da für...
Detach.
Join.
Muss man den Allocator dann auch wieder klicken?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Willst du Zig als Alternative zu Go lernen?
Ähm, just for fun
Vielleicht ist es gut in Zukunft zu wissen
Es ist ja nie verkehrt, was zu essen
Äh, vielleicht muss ich hier Detach machen
Kann das sein? Detach?
Okay
Boah, zack
Ah
War's das?
Vielleicht?
Moment, der ist immer in use, wenn er gerade Connections gehandelt hat.
Fehlt hier vielleicht irgendwas drinne?
Fehlt hier irgendein Differ oder sowas?
Ist was Closed oder so?
also dass ein request
server
vielleicht hier server die fair oder so was
ja dann habe ich keine ahnung warum der hängen bleibt chat jemand von euch eine
klare idee wir können höchstens chat gpt mal fragen
in des six programm ort mainz open after control c
Wenn du den Debug Allocator benutzt, kannst du Detect Leaks machen.
Alter, das wird aber advanced hier.
Your Shingport 8080 remains open after press.
Your server loop never exits.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass es daran liegt.
Ganz ehrlich, das wäre doch Fail, oder?
Wenn das nicht aufgeräumt wird am Ende.
Signal Handling and Clean Shutdown.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass man das machen muss.
Make the listeners close.
Das ist so typische
sinnlos Chat-GPT-Antwortung.
Du kannst es auch so machen, aber in deinem Fall
geht das nicht.
Das ist immer geil, ne?
Naja, gut.
Da fällt uns bestimmt noch
irgendwas ein.
schickt mir mal den code als paste bin ich krieg da schon selbst raus meint also was
jetzt jetzt jetzt machen wir einen den debug allocator aha der debug allocator
wie war in rast proponsorft dann haben wir dafür aber dann rast rast syntax mit der
bekämpfen müssen so und jetzt sage ich hier anstatt allocator muss ich jetzt
muss ich jetzt hier den benutzen drin oder wie ich habe keine ahnung was ich
hier mache
das bleibt immer hängen
Moment, das kann es doch jetzt nicht sein.
Irgendwo muss das doch hier hängen.
Respond.
Wir suchen noch mal kurz hier in diesem Beispiel.
Haben die hier irgendwas drin stehen?
Request.
Ja.
Example SIG.
Start a basic HTTP-Server.
Perfekt.
Gucken wir mal rein, wie der Code von dem dann aussieht am Ende.
YouTube, please.
Das liegt bestimmt an dieser Endlosschleife hier.
Aber das ist trotzdem eklig.
Okay, wir scrollen jetzt hier ein bisschen vor.
Wild, True,
ja, genau das gleiche
machen wir auch.
D-Init, Server,
D-Init, genau das gleiche
machen wir auch.
Stream,
das ist exakt das, was wir auch haben.
Nice, es ist exakt das, also es ist wirklich
fast 1 zu 1 das, was wir
auch haben.
Was ist mit dem Thread Join?
Wenn ich Ctrl-C drücke, da wird ja hier nichts mehr ausgeführt.
Wo soll ich es denn joinen?
Außerdem kann ich das nicht joinen.
Das hängt ja im Hintergrund die ganze Zeit.
Aber das liegt nicht an dem Background Thread.
Der bleibt ja nur hängen, wenn ich Connections händle.
Also irgendwas ist da nicht richtig.
Dann müssen wir das jetzt anders machen.
Dann müssen wir irgendwie Signals handeln.
Wobei, da habe ich eigentlich keinen Bock drauf.
Brauchst du die Init vom Server immer in der Hand?
Ja, ja, das braucht man immer.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Das ist eine gute Frage, Chat.
Braucht man das wirklich immer?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Mit bei Quarkus.
Kann das vielleicht sogar sein?
Okay, ich hab ne Idee.
Wartet mal.
Ach nee.
Connection?
Nee, nee, das muss, das muss, das muss da drin, ne?
Das muss da rein, weil
ich krieg ja diesen IO-Reader
hier nur von diesem Connection-Ding.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist so richtig.
Das ist...
es ist eklig in der hand anwendung oder sagen wir ein bisschen unintuitiv in der
anwendung aber ich glaube das muss so sein
receive hat ich muss ich muss glaube ich echt signals handeln kann es sein
Ich muss signals handeln
Okay sick hände control signal darf das ist aber das ist aber echt echt
Was ist denn error die fair
In addition to an
an konzerts ich es mit der fahrt expert on block exit pass
only if the function with an error formel blog man das brauchen wir nicht
ja aber was soll ich denn noch aufräumen es ist ja nichts da guck hier wir
kommentieren den thread aus der ist es nicht
Bam, Address in Use.
Da ist es nicht.
Das ist irgendwas hier in diesem Handling.
Oder ist es ein Bug oder so? Keine Ahnung.
Aber hier gibt es nichts drin aufzuräumen.
Muss ich random irgendwie aufräumen?
Nee.
Das suckt.
ich also signal handling aber wirklich kein reader writer vielleicht nee ich
ich connecte doch die ich habe doch hier den stream zu klaus ich habe den
thread eben aus kommentiert wo gestartet wird das hängt immer noch
Also das verstehe ich.
SIG remains port remains open after exit.
Du meinst, ich muss hier?
Das kann man gar nicht closen.
Naja.
Das ist irgendwie doof.
Wir ignorieren das jetzt einfach mal.
Ähm.
Kann man vielleicht sagen, dass der...
Irgendwie nicht warten soll und das gleich freigeben oder sowas?
Irgendwie.
Willisten Options?
Pause non-blocking.
Nee.
Oder?
Reuse Address
Snapped, moin
Reuse Address true
Easy
Gepfix
Wir haben zwar immer noch einen Zombie Prozess
Aber egal
Der Port wird wieder benutzt
Scheiß auf Zombie Prozesse
Fixed.
Kunst.
Okay, next.
Wie kriegen wir jetzt, wir brauchen eine
Schminktipps,
wenn das nächste Video mit dem
Friseur kommt.
Ups, was ist, wenn ich da drauf drücke?
Cancel.
Cancel, cancel.
So, wir haben es geschafft.
Jetzt ist die Frage,
wie kriegen wir Prometheus-Metriken,
das ist ja immer so
mein Standardtest
bei neuen Sachen, hier exportiert.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt,
gibt es sowas wie SIG-Packages?
Gibt es da so ein Übersicht?
Sigistry.
Guck mal hier.
Prometheus.
SIG-Prometheus.
Das klingt schon mal gut.
HTTP.
Und Matrix.
Aha.
Okay, das ist 10 Monate alt.
Das hier ist 3 Monate alt.
Okay.
Was ist denn besser?
In SIG gibt es keine zentrale Package Registry.
Sowas wie Cargo ist schon nice.
Okay, Matrix.
Hier gibt es ein Beispiel.
Import Matrix.
Matrix was?
Initialize Noob.
What?
Matrix.
Counter, Gauch, Gorge, wie man das ausspricht.
Visualize Matrix.
Write Matrix.
Äh.
Was will das von mir?
Wie include ich überhaupt eine Library?
ein example für oder so
das ist irgendwie ein beispiel für wie man
genau sap
hier haben sie ein beispiel für haute ette leiber also ich will jetzt nicht
selbst sondern das an sich patch minus minus safe hat also so
gibt es da keinen ordentlichen package manager oder was ist das
okay das hat schon mal funktioniert aber das ist eklig also warum gibt es da keine ich
weiß nicht will ich unbedingt sagen package punkt jason aber irgendwie irgendwas in der richtung
in die xml oder pop xml keine irgendwas
aber das war es ja noch nicht anscheinend und jetzt muss man in your bild sick import
What?
Was ist Zon?
Ach hier, da stehen noch die Dependencies schon drin.
Okay, Moment, Moment, nur dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Das hier ist quasi so eine Art Package.json.
das ist quasi sowas wie package.json aber das heißt nicht dass es automatisch in meinem bild
inkludiert ist das muss ich jetzt wohl noch irgendwie von hand machen heißt ich gehe hier rein
das heißt ich gehe hier rein und okay wir tragen jetzt überall matrix
ok ich glaube ich habe copy paste das jetzt einfach und das war es jetzt oder wie
Okay
Leute, ich hab wirklich nicht
den Hauch einer Ahnung
was ich hier gerade mache
Und jetzt
Constmetrics import
Und dann sowas hier
Matrix.
Das sieht doch schon ganz gut aus.
Ich weiß nicht, Syntax ist teilweise schon ein bisschen
Painstamp.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen
finde ich es ganz angenehm bis jetzt.
So, gerade Brain-Aff.
So, also jetzt habe ich das hier drin.
So, wir machen mal diesen Kram da oben weg.
Connected reicht mir.
So, mal gucken, ob es noch kompiliert.
Anscheinend, anscheinend
kompiliert das noch, okay.
Und was macht der Dude hier jetzt?
Das heißt, ich kann, okay, wir setzen die
Metriken jetzt mal, wir setzen die Metrix jetzt mal
auf hier. Metrix.connected.set
Oh nein, wir sind keine Zoomer, es ist nicht
so und jetzt initialize metrics man to be called once an application startup
Ich copy-paste mir das mal.
matrix im matrix counter connected okay das ist das einzige was übrig ist sondern mal gucken ob
ich jetzt was gelernt habe in sich wenn ich jetzt sage ich hier in matrix da will er options haben
Options ist immer dieses komische Konstrukt hier
Exclude
So ein bisschen hilfe text wäre auch nice
Exclude ja
Was denn gibt es da vielleicht in der gar kuba gibt examples
Main
Ja, dachte ich mir Lip.
Matrix.
Initialize Matrix.
Hä?
Muss gucken, wo das aufgerufen wird.
Das ist doch in Main.
Präfix, Lehrer String, Exclude 0.
Obviously.
Was sonst?
Ganz klar.
So, funzt es jetzt noch?
Ah, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich muss das noch trycatchen.
Ah, es funzt.
Okay.
So.
Okay, okay, okay.
Also jetzt haben wir unser Metrix-Kram angelegt.
Wir werden die Sachen jetzt updaten.
Hier, Moment.
Wartet mal, random.
Das machen wir hier im Background.
Background Thread.
Updating.
Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
einmal in der Sekunde ist okay.
Random.
Okay.
Metrics werden gesetzt einmal in der Sekunde.
Zu auf irgendeinem random Wert.
Das muss jetzt erstmal ausreichen.
So.
Und jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Wie kriege ich die Metrics
in meinen
HTTP-Output rein?
Achso, äh...
Ja gut, ähm...
Wie krieg ich die Matrix in mein HTTP-Output rein?
Hmm...
Also, das da?
Matrix?
Warte mal, ich hab doch da irgendwas gesehen.
Die haben doch hier irgendwas mit Write drin.
Guck mal hier. Write Matrix.
Write Matrix.
Lip. Write.
Hier.
M. Write Matrix
Writer.
Das können wir jetzt bestimmt auf
Standard Out raushauen. Wobei
Standard Out wollen wir... Wir schreiben es erstmal
auf Standard Out raus.
Machen wir mal.
M.
Punkt Write
und
Matrix.
So, und jetzt brauchen wir sowas wie Standard Out.
Standard I.O.
Oder ist es
Writer?
Ne, Standard I.O.
Writer.
Standard
Error
Out.
Ne, ähm.
Keine Ahnung.
äh, sick, get, stand it out, writer.
Standard FS, file, stand it out.
Alter, wie soll man denn, wie soll man denn da drauf kommen?
File, stand it out.
Nee.
Nee, das ist es schon mal nett.
Oder?
Nee.
Okay, das ist schon mal falsch.
Boah, ey.
Wie kriegt man denn einen Writer
zu Standard-Out?
Standard.
Da gibt es ein Pfeil.
Oh, fuck, Alter.
Wie funzt das?
Monk HS.
also so schon mal nicht
das ist das ist next level schiff über was auf gibt so was wie i o punkte interface
es gibt so was
Vielleicht dann und davor machen?
Ne.
Hier. Standard
FS, File, Writer, Standard,
File, Standard, Out, Buffer, Interface.
Wat?
Monks, was?
Ah, ne.
und jetzt hier einen buffer ist geil wie kompliziert 0w kompliziertes was sein
kann nach standard auszuschreiben aber wenn das muss jetzt und pack an itch
Okay, okay, try, try.
Es compiled, Leute, es compiled.
Aber es
write-et nix zu Standard out.
Muss ich das noch flushen oder irgendwie
sowas?
Flush?
So?
Wow.
Jetzt ist einfach mal komplett
in die Luft geflogen.
Ride failed.
The fuck?
Wie kompliziert ist es denn
fast nach Standard Out zu schreiben?
Meine Musik ist wieder abgekackt.
Die Fallflush.
What the fuck?
Mach doch einen Debugprint.
Ja, und dann?
Ich will doch das hier.
Ich will das hier irgendwo hinschreiben, ja?
Okay.
Der Chat, der Chat
macht
Der Chat hat mir was geschickt
Okay, okay
Chat, ich mach das so, wie ihr das geschrieben habt
Also, das da
Standard Outfile
Buffer, Standard Outwriter
Standard Outwriter
Buffer
stahl wort daher wie kompliziert please so und das will ich jetzt drei m dort
right und matrix und weiter der da
wenn an die hier muss und ich muss
Das Funst?
Moment, also, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Ich glaube, das ist die komplizierteste Art und Weise, wie ich je was auf Standard-Out rausgeschrieben habe.
Wer hat sich das denn ausgedacht?
Das ist ja in C++ einfacher und das will schon was heißen.
Das ist ja voll durch die Brust ins Auge, Alter.
WTF?
Okay, das kann man wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen verkürzen.
Irgendwie so.
Und das braucht man auch nicht.
Also das...
So müsste es auch gehen.
Ah ne, da kann ich die Standard-Outflush...
What the fuck, Alter.
Okay, schön ist was anderes.
Das Schöne ist echt was anderes.
Jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht.
Jetzt habe ich es destroyed.
Okay, aber es funzt noch. Nice.
Okay.
Wir wissen zumindest, die Metrics sind schon mal drin.
Jetzt ist die Preisfrage.
Wie kann ich das
hier in die Response schreiben?
Die Response nimmt ja nur
einen String quasi an.
Oder einen
Byte-Array quasi.
Wie kriege ich
das hier zu einem Byte-Array?
Das heißt, okay, dann machen wir jetzt mal eine Funktion.
Function,
ähm, ich hab keine Ahnung, Matrix
to
String oder so.
So, Return-Type.
Wie gibt man den denn da hier an?
Hier, so, Ausrufezeichen.
U8
Okay
Ähm
Das kommentiere ich mal aus hier
Also
Jetzt geht das wie
Also ich brauche hier einmal meine
Matrix
So ich brauche jetzt so quasi so
Ich muss einen Writer
Für
So einen Buffer Writer oder sowas
Brauche ich
Vielleicht geht das auch mit Standard-FMT?
Dass man da irgendwie sagen kann...
Writer oder so?
Nee.
Das gibt keine...
Format-Writer.
Ne, so ist das schon mal...
So ist das schon mal nett.
Wenn das Ding Fixed-Size ist, würde ich dem Standard-Arrow-Writer Fixed...
Ne, ist es ja nicht.
Ist nicht Fixed-Dice.
Irgendwas Dynamisches.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Standard.
I.O.
Writer.
Gibt es vielleicht auch sowas wie Alloc?
Allocate?
Was?
Arraylist.
What?
In it müsste es geben.
Da unten gibt es auch immer in it.
In it.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was ich gerade hier mache.
Und das gibt jetzt was?
Das gibt jetzt eine Liste, oder wie?
Try bestimmt.
Ne, kein Try.
Eine Liste.
Und...
Da muss ich bestimmt...
Aber ich habe da schon D-Init gelesen.
Sonst Memory-Leaks wahrscheinlich.
So.
Aber wie kriege ich jetzt von der Liste?
So kann ich ja wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Oder?
Moment.
Das funzt?
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das funzt.
Content gleich ist Kunst.
Content Matrix to String.
Da muss ich bestimmt ein Try davor machen.
Okay.
Na klar geht das nicht so einfach.
Natürlich.
Okay.
I.O.Writer Phone.
Also das ist falsch.
so habe ich nicht irgendwas in dem rast guide gelesen zum thema list ist das
überhaupt eine list
das ist einfach mal so genannt ist das jetzt eine ist es nicht
Ach, kommt mal hier, Writer.
Guck mal da.
Writer.
Bam.
Ah, ähm, Pointer?
Was jetzt?
Function with non void return type
Achso, ich returne nix.
Achso.
Also, return
list
Ne.
List ist nicht.
Wie kriege ich jetzt ein U8 aus einer List raus?
Written.
Was macht written?
Written hat keine Hilfe.
Kein Hilfetext gibt es nicht.
To ArrayList.
To Own Slice.
Sind wir jetzt in Rust?
Nicht der Drill.
Ne.
To. Was war das?
to own it slice.
Dann bestimmt
try davor.
Okay.
Das vonzt, obviously vonzt das.
Hahaha.
Keine Ahnung, Alter.
Ey, guck mal.
Das, es geht.
Guck mal, der gibt meine Metriken hier auf
HTTP zurück.
Was passiert, wenn ich written verwende?
Was ist written überhaupt?
Das ist ja so absolut nichts.
Nichts sagen.
Written.
Okay.
Da tut sich gar nichts, wenn ich written verwende.
Weiß ja auch nicht, was es macht, weil es keinen Hilfetext hat.
Lassen wir das mal lieber so.
Das hat funktioniert.
Okay, dann können wir diesen ganzen Shit hier weg machen.
Leaken wir Memory?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Leaken wir hier Memory, Leute?
Das kann schon sein.
Das kann schon sein, dass wir da Memory leaken.
Was kommt denn da zurück?
Ne, wir können hier kein Memory leaken.
glaube ich nicht, dass wir Memory leaken.
Wir können das ja nicht aufräumen oder so.
Nee, ich glaube nicht,
dass wir Memory, Memory leaken.
Das glaube ich nicht.
So.
Also so, aber Chat, ich muss sagen, oder
oder frage ich mal euch gefragt,
so schlecht sieht das gar nicht aus, oder?
Das ist doch relativ gut lesbar. Also ich muss sagen,
es ist besser lesbar als Rust.
Meiner Meinung nach.
So wirklich schön ist diese Syntax hier nicht, aber ich finde es auf jeden Fall besser lesbar als Rust.
Aber nicht besser lesbar als Go, auch nicht besser lesbar als C Sharp.
Aber es ist okay.
Das I.O. Interface gefällt mir auch nicht.
Ich glaube nach Matrix, das Ding sollte ein Allocator-Free-Content sein.
Wirklich?
Muss man das machen?
Ja, das wäre jetzt eklig,
wenn ich das von Hand machen müsste.
Okay, muss ich?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe gedacht, es checkt das Ding.
Komisch.
Naja, Chat, ich glaube euch das jetzt mal,
dass man das machen muss.
Aber wie soll ich es denn differen?
Du meinst quasi sowas hier?
Aber wenn ich hier einen differ mache, ne?
Wenn ich hier sowas hier mache...
Dann...
Ne, das muss ich da unten machen.
So, ne?
Das heißt, selbst wenn das hier fehlschlägt, wird noch gefreed.
Was das wird?
Das ist ein...
Ich übe, wie man SIG programmiert.
Das hat jetzt keinen tieferen Nährwert.
Das ist ein
Webserver, der Metriken auf
Port 8080 zurückliefert
Und welche Metriken
Random zahlen
Weil ich wissen will, wie es funktioniert
Das hat keinen tieferen Sinn
So, nächste Preisfrage ist
Wie label ich Metriken?
Auch nicht verkehrt zu wissen
Ich habe doch hier irgendwas von Labels vorhin gesehen, oder?
Label?
Label Vector Matrix.
Aha.
Guck mal da.
Sowas braucht man da.
Okay, das copy-paste ich jetzt und dann versuche ich mal zu verstehen, was da eigentlich passiert.
Connected.
Gauch.
Gauch weg.
so also der value ist ein u32 okay das da hinten ist randoms truck wo ich keine ahnung
habe was das bedeuten soll und dann kann man das darum war das ist also das ist jetzt schon
ein bisschen eklig und wie geht das jetzt im init? Ja, das muss ich jetzt mal angucken. Also was?
M gleich
Metrix connected innet allocator connected
ob das ist ja aberlich und das da kann man jetzt Labels setzen oder wie mit das sieht
richtig hässlich aus, da gebe ich dir recht.
Ah, set gibt es nicht.
Punkt set.
Warum gibt es Punkt set nicht?
Das sieht richtig hässlich aus.
Ach, Labels muss man
jetzt. Da muss man bestimmt wieder diese
komische Syntax hier machen.
Ah, name.
Okay, name, Kekkel.
Und jetzt hier
ein Random Value.
Allerdings haben wir jetzt ein int32
hier.
uns nicht beim status muss man ach das ist welche labels ich haben kann okay
status brauchen wir nicht die treue
frei
Oh man, Alter, was?
Cannot return error.
Gibt es ein Ausrufezeichen davor?
Dann kannst du ein Error dran.
So.
Kunst, wir haben ein Label dran.
Nee, ich brauche keinen Status.
Status, das sind ja nur Labels hier.
Die kann ich ja frei wählen.
Das muss nicht Name heißen.
Ja, die Syntax ist schon eklig, oder?
Die Syntax ist schon abartig hier.
Das hier auch.
Also,
da weiß ich nicht,
ob ich damit so happy bin.
So,
jetzt probieren wir noch was aus.
Wo nutzt man das?
Gar nicht.
Ich glaube, es gibt so gut wie
keine Verbreitung, was
SIG angeht, von irgendwelchen Tools
und Sachen.
Für was ist das?
Dass ich lerne, wie man SIG...
Ich wollte mir das einfach nur angucken.
So, jetzt haben wir hier...
Jetzt müssen wir nochmal gucken,
ob das Binary, was ich erzeugt habe,
ob das jetzt auch
immer noch auf allen Linux-Dingern läuft.
Müsste.
Müsste eigentlich.
Gucken wir nochmal.
Gehen wir nochmal rein.
Repos.
Sick.
Matrix.
Champ.
Äh.
Docker.
Run.
Ubuntu.
1204.
Sick.
Das ist schon nice.
Also.
Das hat man in Go auch.
Ja.
Aber.
Ähm.
dass die Binary quasi static sind
und auf uralt Linux laufen.
Das ist schon nice.
Du kannst das Binary einfach neben rüber kopieren und es geht.
Ghosty ist sick.
Okay.
Stimmt, Bann.
Du hast recht.
Bann ist auch...
Ja, das habe ich ganz vergessen.
Okay, Bann dürfte wahrscheinlich mit Abstand das Größte sein.
Ähm.
BUN wurde letztens gekauft.
Nicht von OpenAI,
sondern von
Entropic oder wie die
äh, genau, Entrophic, genau.
Entropic oder wie die heißen, gell?
Aber BUN bleibt angeblich immer noch Open Source,
sagen sie.
Entropic, Entrophic, Entropic,
wenn man das schreibt.
und ausspricht.
So, also, das haben wir jetzt.
Das finde ich ganz nice, wie das
ging mit Sig.
Das hat Arduino auch behauptet.
Ist es bei Arduino denn nicht so
gewesen oder nicht so gekommen?
Ist Arduino
nicht nicht mehr open source oder ja die wurden auch verkauft ich weiß ich weiß
aber ist die sind die schlechter geworden
qualcomm hat arduino gekauft jetzt keine open hardware mehr gut das ist
halt immer so ein bisschen das sack es hat ja auch viele leute bedenken als microsoft
damals github gekauft hat und sind dann abgewandert und jetzt werden ihre projekte
nicht mehr gefunden ich kann es schon nachvollziehen ich war microsoft hat auch
schon viel gekauft und komisches zeug gemacht so aber chat ich würde sagen meine gehirnkapazität
neigt sich dem ende zu ich würde sagen haben wir genug sich ausprobiert für
heute ich gehe jetzt noch mal an die frische luft ist nicht auch erst von
github weg video schauen ich gehe jetzt erst mal was wirklich die sind weg
tatsächlich ach guck mal das haben die erst vor 14 tagen gepostet hat die sind
abgewandert.
Interessant. Warum?
Was haben sie für Probleme?
Free BSD Support.
Okay.
Aha.
Das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen, dass die weg sind.
Nun ja, aber jetzt noch mal ganz zum Schluss.
Guckt mal, wie nice das jetzt mit den Containern ist.
Wir sind jetzt fertig entwickeln.
Und ich sage einfach jetzt nur
DevPod Destroy und
äh, delete, nicht destroy, ich kann nur
delete, zack, guck, 7 GB wieder freigegeben
und jetzt sind wir wieder clean.
Alles wieder weggeschmissen, was wir heute entwickelt haben, außer natürlich
den Source Code, der ist immer noch da. Übrigens, wir sollten,
bevor wir mal hier den Git ignore machen, sollten wir vielleicht mal reinschreiben
sig out und äh, sig
Cash habe ich noch gesehen.
Genau.
Das finde ich nice.
Das mit den Containern, das gefällt mir.
Das hat mir im Stream nicht so gut gefallen.
Aber jetzt, nachdem ich es ein bisschen benutzt habe,
finde ich es eigentlich sehr nice.
Okay.
Chat, ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Ich gehe jetzt an die frische Luft.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.